then fiber to the home or ftth wow where to
start telecom acronyms are
chinese for you adsl vdsl xdsl copper
broadband fiber cable bandwidth
fttc fttb ftth next
generation networks stop actually it's really
simple basically what matters  for
you it's having a
fast internet connection to send and
receive music photos or videos
in an instant call at the best
price or even better make video calls
to your family your friends
work from home as if you
were at the office watch your
TV programs in high definition and whenever you
want with catch up tv watch
videos on demand play online with
your friends instantly save your
data on the internet it is shared with
whoever you want et cetera et cetera
de  all the technologies giving access
to the internet fiber to the home is
the fastest and most
reliable solution
and the other technologies then the
mobile connections for example are
much slower especially
when many of us connect in the same
area
is also slower than ftth
satellite transmission suffered a delay
which causes a lag and makes
conversations h
and other technologies like l  DSL
uses metal cables which are
100 times slower than fiber
optics
downloading an hd video can
take you a good hour and even more
provided that no other
family member is surfing at the same time your
children n  have never grumbled about this
with ftth, on the other hand, fiber
brings you an ultra-fast connection at
home
by what a miracle
simply because optical fibers
are ultra-thin glass filaments
that conduct light at the speed
of light  say something
well that's exactly what we're talking about
imagine for a moment with home fiber
you download a movie in
minutes even if your kids  ts
are on a video call with their
grandparents plus ftth is
future proof and it offers virtually unlimited capacity
several million homes in europe
are already connected to home fiber
and you it's for when
and